hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines where i have researched the
YouTube culture and it turns out that I
have made a grave mistake in the way
I've been playing every game ever
because it is not me and doing all of
this it is us
and if I am doing something in this game
it's got to be us doing it so um today
we are doing some road work as you can
see but that is definitely not the main
thing because this is an episode in
which we I was almost going to say I are
going to make loads of new neighborhoods
because that is necessary I don't even
have that much commercial in no
residential demand but we figured that
we would do it anyway because I won that
population and that is a mistake that I
made at that point because figured if I
want to have this industrial demand go
down and my residential demand go up
I'll just have to build more forest
industry and that was not the greatest
plan ever but it worked out for now
because it allowed my other demands to
go up for in just a minute
and then it didn't work anymore and also
creating all those big zones with
commercial areas suddenly will probably
leave them with not enough customers or
not enough workers so that is not really
the greatest plan but I really had the
urge to expand upon our city in this
episode so I really wanted to do that at
the cost of whatever it would cost but
in this episode I'm going to add a
couple of new neighborhoods but my
favorite of that is probably Amsterdam
which is going to be all the way on the
right of the city over there next to the
highway next to the Solow that's not
yeah that is a solar power plant and
that is going to happen right now with
the curvy roads as you may know but also
some more straight roads because I have
so many curvy roads right now in the
entire city is one big suburb I I guess
I could also throw in one or two
straight roads so there you go that is a
that's a new kana thing for this city
and some rings now the idea behind this
was originally I'm going to make these
rings and then it's gonna look like
Amsterdam and then I make the Rings and
it doesn't look like Amsterdam at all
and Who am I
you're kidding with this but it's still
pretty cool region though and definitely
a good area to expand because it's got
on highway next to it it's somewhat
close to the center and definitely not
going to have too many traffic problems
with that and it's also close through
some good services so good area to
expand and then there's the fact that
those solar plants shouldn't be all the
way out of this city like that it just
kind of feels off when they're so far
away from the rest of the city and just
three solar power plants just right
there that just kind of it just looked
awkward that's why I figured but then
again that's that's something I've been
worrying about in City games for a long
time is the fact that every single city
no matter how small it is needs to have
his own needs to have its own power
plants and I'm not really sure if that
really works that way especially for a
city with less than 50,000 inhabitants
because that mmm I don't know does that
really need a power plant I think that
just uses the power that the general
area users from either nuclear energy
because I'm I would be completely fine
with that or something else and but that
that's just me nagging about that and
this is me thinking
once again all right we need to add more
industrial zones because the demand is
high so I'm gonna build more forests and
at some point I ended up having so much
forest industry and you might be
thinking silver I worry why are you
doing this this is not really the most
efficient way to do this but I was
trying to not get as much of the
pollution and the forest things you know
as inefficient as they may be I do like
those forest industry farms whatever
they are but they look hardcore so
that's why I added them it's definitely
not the best idea I've ever had but you
know in sometimes you just need to do
stupid things and then later you come to
realize that they were stupid but then
you know you've learned from your
mistakes and there's not an excuse to
make mistakes but whatever and this is
still a somewhat old episode because
despite me trying to actually get rid of
the delay and
upload more frequently than I am
recording that so far hasn't really
succeeded yet so this is an episode from
before the one point 0.1 B patch which i
think is the name which is ridiculously
you know it is like a mathematical
equation at this point I don't know why
they made it like that but not right now
the you have like extra road options and
I'm going to explain that later but
essentially the game has changed and
that is why I am NOT adding extra Road
options or other boat fixes and another
thing is at this point I haven't
installed too many mods yet and I think
soon after this episode which might
actually be their first episode after
this I installed a mod which gets rid of
the weird purple color on the ground
when you have pollution because that is
kind of a gamebreaking thing in the
sense that it's not very realistic to
have your ground go purple when it's
when there's like pollution so kind of
wanted to get rid of that and I did so
that's cool and this is yet again
another industrial area and watching
this I need to stop saying silver I
don't do this because this is a terrible
ideas over out what are you doing
but it's no I can stop myself at this
point this the silver at former pastors
goes on to create industrial zones where
he should have built offices and even at
this point the demand for industrial and
commercial are pretty high higher than
the industrial demand so why this past
silver is not doing that I have no idea
though he's going to soon you'll see
that especially in this area this is
gonna be a pretty big area with both
commercial and well residential stuff
however their kind of place it in
Islands they don't really go well
together it's just one big area full of
commercial stuff and one big area for
residential stuff and that is in
hindsight not the best idea ever
and possibly learn didn't work out that
well but silver had figured that looks
good so that's what we want in our city
because after all I kind of prefer
looking good over a very efficient or
great city
so I'm sorry if there's anyone out there
who's looking for a let's play where the
city is extremely efficient and going to
have a huge population and skyscrapers
everywhere and just going to work
perfectly I kind of want to go for a
more realistic city and with realism
I suppose come mistakes and some forts
in city management and that is something
I can't avoid myself so there is my
excuse for doing that I guess but one
thing I would really like to do in this
game and this is a very Dutch thing I
think it's not that common around the
world but over here people just like to
plan neighborhoods beforehand so one the
city management is just like okay we're
gonna build this neighborhood over here
and every single house is going to be
planned and built in a way that we agree
with and it's not the people themselves
building it but rather an entire
neighborhood is planned out and that is
something that at the moment you can't
really do in this game and I mean you
can lay out the road pattern and decide
what people are going to build where but
you are not the person building it and
there are no row houses or terraces
whatever you want to call them or big
flat blocks that are identical and where
you can actually decide what they're
going to look like and hopefully that's
going to be added at some point by
morning but then again I have a pretty
lengthy list of things that I would like
to see in this game but myself I'm quite
too lazy to actually implement them and
one of those things which I've been
thinking about is ski lifts I would so
love to be able to build a ski resort in
this game because you've got the
mountains and you can build your own
cities and everything but I was looking
at those mountains and I was like yeah
those are kind of just annoying right
now but if we would be able to get ski
lifts that would be so amazing so oh and
that there is the achievement so finally
getting that that 36,000 population but
I think that's not a a weight that is
actually an achievement where you can
buy a new plot of land so there was an
issue because since the city is so
spread out and I feel like this city is
more spread out than the creators of the
game intend you to do because this is
such a huge city and it doesn't really
have
too much high-rise that I'm running out
of land and I am very much afraid that
in the later stages of this game I am
actually going to run out of the plots
that I have and I know that I still have
enough land available but it's not
enough to actually make the city look
very organic in its shape because there
are just some areas where it borders the
city border and they get this straight
line and that is very American and that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's bad
but you know it's something that I can't
want to avoid with the curvy road
patterns and European feel to the city
as a whole in general but I I guess I'll
find out about that because it might
just turn out that in the end I am
actually going to build more high-rises
in the city as it grows or that the
achievements don't really take that much
of a population growth to buy a new plot
of land but either one of those could be
possible and I guess I'll just see in
the future but an organic growth of the
city is definitely something I am
aspiring even if it does come at the
cost of a less great looking city that
there are just some times when making
mistakes is a Ketones actually white
turns out to be a good thing because
seriously sometimes when you mess up on
the city layout planning and then then
it might just be the case that it turns
out to be an awesome thing and it was
actually good for the city after all and
that is the kind of mistakes that I'm
going for because that that is actually
the best way to get that organic kind of
city layout it's hard to actually plan
and get organic layout because even if
you plan it you're still going to see
that I'm not organic shape in it which
is definitely why I like jumping into
building neighborhoods without much
planning beforehand and just creating
random road curves and everything just
like you're doodling on paper in a
boring class I think that's how I like
my city building yeah except with this
Amsterdam area though which I'm quite
happy about and as you can see this area
is very planned and there is high rise
on the sides there and the courthouse in
the middle and there's going to be a
park between that and that is going to
be a pretty cool kind of very planned
communist area but I still like it
and it's gonna have those typical
suburban small houses around it but I
felt like I definitely need something
like that for a city this size and I am
going at some point to delete parts of
the downtown to make the downtown bigger
and add more higher residential in the
middle of the city because you know if
the city grows more it doesn't really
make much sense to have small houses in
the middle of it but anyway that's it
for this episode so thank you for
watching and I'll see you on the next
episode in which I am almost going to do
a real-time episode but not quite next
episode is going to be the last normal
episode and then I'm going to do a
real-time tour of the city and I think
it might actually take another episode
but I'll see you about that but anyway
I'll see you next time